who'd the new spider-man far from home
trailer oh just for you guys exclusively
because sometimes we just want to show
our support and you guys have been so
amazing to us ever since I got this job
and I guess we just wanted to come in
and say thank you really and that was
our way for a Marvel and Sony to say
thank you and I hope you enjoyed it we
loved it it's amazing to see something
you've worked so hard on become a
reality and then share it with the
people who really want to see it so
again thank you for having us see cxp
it's been amazing hey everyone it's
Warren and I just wanted to do a quick
update on the spider-man far from home
trailer a lot of people have been asking
me about it and been asking me when it's
going to be released especially since
they showed it at CC XP in South Paolo
Brazil it was actually planned and
scheduled to be released the same week
that we got the new Captain Marvel
trailer in the Avengers end game teaser
trailer but they ended up just showing
it at CC XP and not releasing it online
or to the general public so a lot of
people thought that we were going to get
the trailer today on Tuesday and
obviously that did not happen and it's
not because the trailer isn't ready the
trailers ready they actually have two
trailers ready to go and of course they
showed the trailer at CC xB so the
trailer is ready that's not the problem
the problem is actually kind of two
things the first problem is the time gap
between the Avengers endgame teaser
trailer release and the spider-man far
from home teaser trailer release Marvel
and Sony both want more time to go
between the release of The Avengers
in-game trailer and when they release
the spider-man far from home trailer
this makes sense because of course
Marvel is going to want the hype for
Avengers in game to go on for as long as
possible and of course Tony doesn't want
spider-man far from home to get
overshadowed by the Avengers in game
trailer but the second problem is that
Marvel is actually kind of ticked off at
Sony Marvel didn't like Sony's plan for
spider-man far from home it gives away
too much it was already confirmed that
we would get a sequel for spider-man
homecoming after infinity war and then
an infinity war they killed off
spider-man he was a victim of the
decimation so of course everybody thinks
hey he's coming back because there's
another movie to do and this really goes
again
what the rooster brothers told everybody
when they said that the deaths and
infinity war were permanent nobody is
getting brought back to life but now we
have a trailer for spider-man far from
home coming out which clearly shows that
spider-man gets brought back to life
somehow he's not permanently dead and
that takes away from avengers endgame
and Marvel has a problem with that so
there's some problems right now with how
Sony is presenting far from home because
it could take away from Avengers endgame
so they're really just trying to give
the trailer some distance from Avengers
in game but it still should be dropping
relatively soon it's not coming today
and there have actually been reports
that it's not even coming this week
that's what I've heard so far and of
course if I hear any news I'll update
you all obviously Marvel has the right
to be concerned that the far from home
trailer will give away too much for
Avengers in game but what do you all
think the Spider Man far from home
trailer will show let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and don't
forget about my giveaway I'm giving away
a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]